[Music]
so I woke up this morning to see that
Ben Affleck has officially announced
that he is departing his role as The
Dark Knight of course if you've been
keeping up to date with DC movie news on
the past couple of years you'll know
that he's pretty much been the
Schrodinger's cat
or should I say Schrodinger's bat of the
comics world with they're constantly
being speculation as to whether he's in
or out
however on Twitter today affleck
gracefully announced that he was
stepping down from the role by
confirming a news article from Deadline
Hollywood in case you can't read in the
tweet Affleck says excited for the
Batman in summer 2021 and to see Matt
Reeves vision come to life now this
doesn't really come as a big surprise
however it is pretty disappointing
Affleck was someone that got slammed
upon casting by the internet including
me
but one round a lot of people dude his
portrayal in Batman V Superman in which
I think was by far the best part of that
film he managed to carry the menace
fear-driven crime fighter that to me is
at least the most comic-book accurate
version that we've had in a live action
film it's pretty clear that Affleck
wasn't too happy with the direction
either you only have to Google sad
Affleck to see thousands of memes from
the press tour of BBS and know that he
wasn't exactly ecstatic with the
reception on the film here was a guy who
was really going through a second
Renaissance in his career and winning
Oscars but had to put this on hold due
to the role also due to Warner Brothers
not really having a clear direction for
the character constant reshoots and
negative press around whether he was
going to continue playing the role after
Justice League I think it just became a
bit too much we've heard for years that
Matt Reeves has wanted to focus on a
younger Batman for a standalone film and
a film focused solely on the character
has been bounced around pretty much
since 2013 when the actor was first cast
that's a lot of time to be in limbo over
things and Affleck poured his heart and
soul into working on the script for the
film with Reeves and Geoff Johns and
then to have it constantly push back it
just must be frustrating obviously this
is disappointing for fans who love this
betrayal but hopefully this will mean
that Warner Brothers fire
just get their head down and sort out
all the problems with this in a magic
universe I really want the DCU to get
back on track as the boys preferred
their comics over Marvel and maybe his
departure is for the greater good even
if it is pretty sad I would of course
love to hear your thoughts on the news
and if you think that this is a positive
or negative thing make sure you leave
them in the comments below and if you
like this video then please give it a
thumbs up and check out my breakdown of
the other big DC property news this week
birds of prey which would be linked at
the end this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]